I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is Hidden Brain. My name is Brandi Drew. I'm from Detroit, Michigan. Brandi Drew has a story that may sound familiar to you, a story of poverty and debt. It's the kind of story that may lead people to quick conclusions, so pay attention to your own. Brandi is now in her late 30s,
我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我的名字叫布兰迪·德鲁。我来自密歇根州底特律。布兰迪·德鲁有一个你可能觉得熟悉的故事，一个关于贫穷和债务的故事。这是一个容易让人迅速下结论的故事，所以请注意你自己的判断。布兰迪现在三十多岁，
a few years ago, her life unraveled. At the time, she ran the dining services department at a senior living facility. She'd been with a company that ran it for more than a decade. One day, she made a mistake. I was just in a rush to get home that was all. Because daycare closes at 6. I get off at 5.
几年前，她的生活分崩离析。当时，她在一家高级生活社区管理餐饮服务部门。她在那家运营该社区的公司工作了十多年。有一天，她犯了一个错误。我当时只是急着回家，仅此而已。因为日托中心6点关门。我5点下班。
It was like maybe a 10 mile drive, busy traffic area. And I knew I had to pick up diapers and the easiest thing for me, I thought would be to pick them up before I picked the baby up. So Brandy stopped at a store, ran in, and grabbed the diapers. She swiped her credit card at the self checkout station and raced out.
车程大约10英里，交通非常繁忙。我知道我得去买尿布，而对我来说最简单的方法，我想就是在接孩子之前先把尿布买好。于是布兰迪在一家商店停下，跑进去拿了尿布。她在自助结账台刷了信用卡，然后冲了出去。
It turns out she used the wrong card, not her own, but the company credit card. But it was crazy as I didn't realize at that moment I didn't realize until my supervisor called me in and said, hey, what's this purchase? So has she not said anything? I don't think I would have realized that. Randy carried the card in case she needed to buy dining supplies for work. She'd never had a problem before, never been reprimanded. She thought an apology and an explanation would do.
结果证明她刷错了卡，用的不是她自己的卡，而是公司的信用卡。但疯狂的是，我当时根本没意识到，直到我的主管把我叫去说，嘿，这是什么采购？如果她什么都没说呢？我想我也不会意识到这一点。布兰迪随身带着这张卡，以防她需要为工作购买餐饮用品。她以前从未遇到过问题，也从未受过训斥。她以为道歉加解释就能解决问题。
And her response was, well, you know we have to terminate you. And I'm like, no, I didn't know that. Like, can I just pay you back? It was only, what, 12 bucks? And she said, no, in cases like that, you automatically have to terminate the employee. I just cried. I cried for like a whole day
她的回应是，嗯，你知道我们必须解雇你。我说，不，我不知道。比如，我能把钱还给你吗？才12美元而已。她说，不行，遇到这种情况，你必须自动被解雇。我只是哭。我哭了一整天，
because I couldn't believe it. I didn't want to go home and tell my kids what had happened. I didn't want to tell my husband what had happened. I just didn't know what to do at that point. I felt like a failure as a parent, because I didn't provide a good example, even though it was a mistake.
因为我简直不敢相信。我不想回家告诉孩子们发生了什么。我不想告诉丈夫发生了什么。我当时真的不知道该怎么办。我觉得自己是个失败的父母，因为我没有树立好榜样，尽管这只是一个失误。
Brandy earned more than her husband, so the loss of the job hit hard. She felt like a loser. She tried to bring in money doing odd jobs like cooking takeaway meals, but the stress grew. Brandy and her husband began fighting. She had supported him when he'd been laid off a few years earlier, and she'd expected he'd do the same for her. But he felt a layoff was different.
布兰迪的收入比丈夫高，因此失去工作对她的打击沉重。她觉得自己是个失败者。她试图通过做外卖烹饪等零工来赚钱，但压力越来越大。布兰迪和丈夫开始争吵。几年前丈夫失业时她曾支持过他，她本以为他也会这样对自己。但他觉得被解雇是另一回事。
He was mad that she'd made his stupid mistake. The final argument was that I left out the house that morning. I was going to job interviews. I had two interviews that day and I didn't purchase toilet paper. So when he got home from work that day, there was no toilet paper. When I came in with the kids, you just immediate started yelling. You can't keep yourself together, you can't do this, you can't do that, so I walked right back out the door and I never looked back. Without steady employment and a husband to help with bills, Brandy watched anxiously as her household supplies dwindled. She worried constantly about money. To make ends meet, she ordered a new credit card. The day it arrived,
他很生气她犯了这么愚蠢的错误。最后一次争吵是因为那天早上我离开家去参加面试。我那天有两场面试，但我没有买卫生纸。所以那天他下班回家时，没有卫生纸。我和孩子们刚进门，他就开始大喊大叫。你连自己都管不好，你什么也做不好，于是我转身走出家门，再也没有回头。没有稳定的工作和丈夫来分担账单，布兰迪焦虑地看着家里的物资一天天减少。她无时无刻不在为钱担心。为了维持生计，她申请了一张新信用卡。它到达的那天，
Grandi tore open the envelope. She grabbed the card and ran out the door. I went straight to Walmart and I bought like a family size of toilet paper, family size of laundry detergent like I stocked up on things all at once whether than keeping it handy just in case. So I like maxed it out within the first couple of days that I had it rather than holding on to it for emergency purposes. And in that moment as she was maxing out the credit card on the household supply she needed, Brandy forgot about things that were slightly less pressing.
格兰迪撕开信封。她抓起卡跑出门外。我直接去了沃尔玛，买了一大包家庭装的卫生纸、家庭装的洗衣液，我一次性把东西囤够了，而不是随用随买以备不时之需。所以在拿到卡的前几天，我就把它刷爆了，而不是把它留作紧急备用。就在她为了所需的家居用品刷爆信用卡的那一刻，布兰迪忘记了那些稍微没那么紧急的事情。
What I didn't think about is what about gas money? I didn't consider what gas would cost. That was like the biggest thing. It was always hard to have gas. And of course, there was the credit card bill itself. The first two months I paid the minimum payment and then I just stopped paying because I couldn't afford to pay. I didn't pay that card off until I got my tax refund the following year.
我没想到的是油钱怎么办？我没有考虑汽油会花多少钱。那是最大的问题。油钱总是很难凑够。当然，还有信用卡账单本身。前两个月我只还了最低还款额，后来就索性不还了，因为根本付不起。直到第二年拿到退税，我才把那张卡还清。
By the time I paid it off it was over $800 for a $500 card. More and more, Brandy felt trapped by death. She no longer had options. It came down to pay the bills or feed the kids. It's just overwhelming trying to juggle all of those things and still maintain a certain state of mind so that my children wouldn't see me struggle. In retrospect, Brandy can see the mistakes she made. If she had made a budget for the whole month, she might have remembered she needed to account for gas.
等我还清时，一张500美元额度的卡已经欠了800多美元。布兰迪越来越感到被债务困住。她已经别无选择。归根结底，要么付账单，要么给孩子们买吃的。要同时兼顾所有这些事情，还要保持某种心态不让孩子们看到我的挣扎，这实在是令人窒息。回想起来，布兰迪能看到自己犯下的错误。如果她做了一个一个月的预算，她可能就会记得把汽油钱算进去。
If she had focused on the big picture, she might not have maxed out a credit card she couldn't afford to pay back. Why did Brandy make these mistakes? It's easy to say she was being irresponsible. But here's the thing, she had always been careful and conscientious. Did something cause her to behave differently? To understand why she did this, I want to take you to a completely different time and place, because it reveals something important about Grandi's story. It's 1944, World War II is nearing its end.
如果她把眼光放长远，她可能就不会刷爆一张自己根本无力偿还的信用卡了。布兰迪为什么会犯这些错误？很简单的一句话就是她不负责任。但事实是，她一直以来都是个小心谨慎、认真负责的人。是什么导致她的行为发生了改变？为了理解她为什么这样做，我想带大家回到一个完全不同的时间和地点，因为它揭示了关于格兰迪故事的重要信息。那是1944年，第二次世界大战接近尾声。
Europe is on the verge of mass famine. Aid workers desperately need guidance on how to bring people back from the brink of starvation. Researchers at the University of Minnesota thought they could help. They launched a year-long experiment. As a 2002 documentary made by the University explains, the volunteers were conscientious objectors who still wanted to serve their country. The experiment? The volunteers had to go on a starvation diet. 36 young men, most of them quakers, menonites or church of brethren members,
欧洲正处于大规模饥荒的边缘。救援人员迫切需要指导，以了解如何将人们从饥饿的边缘拉回来。明尼苏达大学的研究人员认为他们可以帮上忙。他们发起了一项为期一年的实验。正如该大学2002年的一部纪录片所解释的，志愿者们都是拒绝服兵役者，但他们仍然想为国家效力。实验内容是什么？志愿者们必须进行饥饿饮食。36名年轻男子，其中大多数是贵格会、门诺会或弟兄会成员，
moved into the south tower of the memorial stadium, which would be their home for a year. Many took courses at the university, even as they grew thinner and thinner. The young men became walking scarecrows. Some grew so weak and bonny they couldn't sit without cushions or raise their arms to wash their hair. I remember being a little bit critical of guys in early part who would lick their plates. I thought that was really pretty crude. Henry Schollberg was one of the volunteers. He recalled the experience in the documentary.
搬进了纪念体育场的南塔，这里将成为他们一年的家。许多人在大学里上课，尽管他们的身体变得越来越瘦。这些年轻人变成了行走的稻草人。有些人变得如此虚弱和骨瘦如柴，以至于不垫垫子就无法坐下，或者无法抬起胳膊洗头。我记得早期时，我对那些舔盘子的家伙有点批判态度。我觉得那太粗俗了。亨利·肖尔伯格是志愿者之一。他在纪录片中回忆了这段经历。
By the time we ran to about the second month of it, I was doing it myself. You just needed every single calorie you could get your hand on. The results of the starvation experiment were eventually published and remain an important academic reference on nutrition, famine, and eating disorders. But recently, two researchers became intrigued with the 70-year-old study for a completely different reason. They were interested in what the lack of food did, not to the body, but to the mind. I think this type of scarcity is almost like an alarm that goes off in the head, that's
到了大约第二个月的时候，我自己也开始这么做了。你只需要你所能弄到的每一卡路里热量。这项饥饿实验的结果最终得以发表，并至今仍是关于营养、饥荒和饮食失调的重要学术参考。但最近，两位研究人员出于完全不同的原因对这项已有70年历史的研究产生了兴趣。他们感兴趣的是食物短缺对身体没有影响，而是对大脑有什么影响。我认为这种稀缺几乎就像大脑中响起的一个警报，在说，
saying, hey, we really need this thing addressed. We really need this thing addressed. This is Sandal Molineathan, a behavioral scientist at the University of Chicago's Boots School of Business. He and a colleague, Eldar Sheffier, a psychology professor at Princeton, had a theory brewing. It went like this, when you feel that something important is missing in your life, your brain starts to focus on that missing thing. When you're really desperate for something, you can focus on it so obsessively, there's no room for anything else. The researchers were just beginning to explore their hypothesis when a colleague mentioned the long ago Minnesota starvation experiment. Elder remembers being immediately fascinated by the study
嘿，我们真的需要解决这个问题。我们真的需要解决这个问题。这是芝加哥大学布斯商学院的行为科学家桑德尔·穆莱纳坦。他和同事埃尔达·沙菲尔（普林斯顿大学心理学教授）当时正在酝酿一个理论。情况是这样的：当你觉得生活中缺少了某个重要的东西时，你的大脑就会开始专注于那个缺失的东西。当你非常渴望某样东西时，你会执着到全神贯注的地步，以至于容不下其他任何东西。研究人员刚开始探索他们的假设时，一位同事提到了很久以前的明尼苏达饥饿实验。埃尔达回忆说，他立刻被这项研究深深吸引，
and how the lack of food affected the minds of the men. They basically were very hungry and couldn't stop eating. In some sense, you'd think, given that they cannot eat, they'd rather be distracted with other things, but in fact, both subconsciously, the level of immediate reaction and their choice of conversation largely was around food. It was actually a sort of tragic comic. I mean, they planned to open restaurants,
以及食物短缺如何影响了这些男人的大脑。他们基本上是非常饥饿，而且无法停止进食。某种意义上，你可能会想，既然他们吃不到东西，他们宁愿被其他事情分散注意力，但事实上，无论是潜意识里即时反应的水平，还是他们选择的话题，基本上都围绕着食物。这其实有点悲喜交加。我的意思是，他们计划开餐馆，
to become restaurateurs, these memorized recipes, they compared food prices at different newspapers. That's what they were doing the whole time. They sat around looking at food-related issues. Even intentional diversions didn't work. Hunger and food had captured their minds. At some point the experimenters just felt sore for them and decided to distract them with a movie, and some of the testimonials were, they showed me this movie, I couldn't
成为餐馆老板，他们背诵菜谱，他们在不同的报纸上比较食物价格。他们整天都在做这些。他们坐在一起研究与食物相关的问题。甚至是刻意的转移注意力也没有用。饥饿和食物已经占据了他们的头脑。在某个时刻，实验人员只是为他们感到难过，决定用一部电影来分散他们的注意力，一些人的证言是，他们给我看了这部电影，我才
care less about the love scenes I wanted to see the meals. Eldar suddenly realized he had seen the same kind of behavior in a completely different setting. He'd done a lot of research on the effects of poverty, and he knew poor people who sometimes behave like the starving men in Minnesota. Poor people who were lacking financial resources found it very hard to think about anything but money,
不在乎什么爱情场面呢，我想看的是饭菜。埃尔达突然意识到，他在一个完全不同的环境中见过这种行为。他对贫穷的影响做了大量研究，他认识一些穷人，他们的行为有时就像明尼苏达那些挨饿的人一样。缺乏经济资源的穷人发现自己很难去思考金钱以外的事情，
or they spend a lot of the cognitive resources, a lot of their attention on financial juggling. If starvation made people obsess over food, poverty made people obsess over how they were going to make ends meet, how to make it to next week. What's uncommon in both cases is that your head is busy with the thing you don't have enough of. The two researchers felt they were on to something. Maybe they thought the human brain is wired to respond to scarcity by tunneling in on the thing that's missing.
或者他们把大量的认知资源、大量的注意力花在了资金周转上。如果饥饿让人对食物产生执念，贫困就会让人对如何维持生计、如何撑到下周产生执念。这两种情况的共同之处在于，你的大脑被你所缺少的那个东西占满了。这两位研究人员觉得自己有了重大发现。也许他们认为，人类的大脑在面对资源稀缺时，会自动通过聚焦于缺失的东西来做出反应。
Sendell says this makes sense from an evolutionary perspective. Picture that you have somebody from 25,000 years ago who's basically a hunter gatherer and who might need to do a variety of things such as you know get water, dover, you know, a lot of resources are needed. When they get hungry, the sort of evolutionary system wants to have an alarm that says, hey, really focus on getting you know, a lot of resources are needed. When they get hungry, the sort of the evolutionary system wants to have an alarm that says, hey, really focus on getting food into the system. And that, I think, is the basic scarcity instinct. We're hungry. And then this thing starts going off in the head saying, do you realize we're hungry? Have I mentioned we're hungry? We're hungry.
桑德尔说，从演化的角度来看，这是合乎情理的。想象一下，你有一个来自25000年前的人，他基本上是一个猎人采集者，可能需要做各种各样的事情，比如找水、捕鹿，你知道，需要大量的资源。当他们感到饥饿时，某种演化系统希望发出一个警报，说，嘿，真的集中精力把资源弄到手。当他们感到饥饿时，演化系统希望发出一个警报，说，嘿，真的集中精力把食物弄进系统里。我认为，这就是基本的稀缺本能。我们饿了。然后大脑里就开始响起这个声音：你意识到我们饿了吗？我提过我们饿了吗？我们饿了。
And it just keeps calling out to you. For Brandy Drew, the alarm might have sounded like this. it keeps calling out to you. For Brandy Drew, the alarm might have sounded like this. You don't have the necessities your family needs. You need to stock up. Stock up now. You need these things. And when she bought the bleach, the family sized pack of toilet paper, the snacks and juice boxes for the kids, the alarm temporarily went silent. I felt relieved that those things, the small things I didn't have
它一直在呼唤你。对布兰迪·德鲁来说，这个警报听起来可能是这样的：它一直在呼唤你。对布兰迪·德鲁来说，这个警报听起来可能是这样的：你没有家人所需的基本生活必需品。你需要囤货。马上囤货。你需要这些东西。当她买下漂白剂、家庭装卫生纸、零食和给孩子们的果汁盒时，警报暂时安静了下来。我感到宽慰的是，那些东西、那些我不需要担心的琐事，
to worry about. But the reprieve from the alarm came at a huge cost. But then like I said two days later it's like okay wait a minute why didn't you save at least a hundred dollars for gas. The answer to that question, Sandel and Aldar believe, has to do with what scarcity did to Brandy. She was so focused on getting the basic necessities that she didn't have the mental capacity to attend to anything else. There's a technical term for this, it's called bandwidth. If you're downloading a movie on your home Wi-Fi network, you might find your email runs a little slower.
但警报的暂时解除付出了巨大的代价。但就像我说的，两天后，就像是，等一下，你为什么不至少存一百美元作油钱？桑德尔和埃尔达认为，这个问题的答案与稀缺对布兰迪产生的影响有关。她太专注于获取基本必需品，以至于没有精神容量去关注其他任何事情。这有一个专业术语，叫做带宽。如果你正在家里的Wi-Fi网络上下载电影，你可能会发现你的电子邮件运行得慢了一点。
The movie is hogging all the available bandwidth. Send the LNLDR, say our minds, work exactly the same way. If your mind is consumed with thoughts about something, there isn't room to think about other stuff. Scarcity fills the mind with intrusive thoughts about what you do not have. It doesn't leave room for anything else. Eldar says there's a simple way to demonstrate this. Imagine trying to hold an 8 digit number in your head. And if I simply ask you to keep in mind, you know, 26717164, that just leaves you less
电影占用了所有可用的带宽。桑德尔和埃尔达说，我们的大脑也是以完全相同的方式运作的。如果你的大脑被关于某件事的想法占据了，就没有空间去思考其他事情了。稀缺会让大脑充满关于你所没有的东西的侵入性想法。它不给其他任何东西留出空间。埃尔达说，有一个简单的方法可以证明这一点。想象一下试图在脑海中记住一个8位数。如果我只是要求你记住，你知道的，26717164，这只会让你
able to attend to other stuff. You eat less well, you pay attention to less things, etc. As you're saying that they did it now and now I didn't hear the rest of the next two sentences because I kind of remember that. I want test you. I want test your promise. But in a sense that's kind of the matter for you. So when you're busy juggling your resources, worrying about how I'm going to pay for dinner and if I pay for dinner, I will not be able to have my certificate school trip. It's that keeping an a average number in your head. There's a reason our minds work this way. Tunneling into something makes you focus on it.
更没有能力去处理其他事情。你吃得不好，你对事情的注意力下降，等等。当你说他们现在做到了，现在我没有听到接下来两句话的剩余部分，因为我有点记得那个。我想测试你。我想测试你的承诺。但在某种意义上，这可以说是你的一个隐喻。所以当你忙于周转资源，担心我怎么付晚饭钱，如果我付了晚饭钱，我就无法参加学校的证书旅行。这就好比在脑子里记住一个A平均数。我们的思维方式这样运作是有原因的。锁定某件事会让你专注于它。
Everything inside the tunnel becomes crystal clear. The problem is, you can't see anything outside the tunnel. People in the poverty tunnel are actually very good at figuring out how to stretch the money they have to make it a tomorrow or the next week. Studies show that the poor tend to be better than the rich at knowing where you can find the best deals, the cheap tube of toothpaste. Someone who is poor is often consumed with finding solutions to immediate problems. How do I get food on the table today? I'm not thinking about problems that are a few weeks away,
隧道内的一切都变得清晰无比。问题是，你看不到隧道外面的任何东西。处于贫困隧道中的人们实际上非常擅长弄清楚如何将现有的钱延展，好撑到明天或下周。研究表明，穷人在知道哪里能找到最便宜的交易、便宜的牙膏管方面往往比富人更在行。一个穷人经常被寻找解决眼前问题的方法所消耗。我今天怎么把饭菜端上桌？我不会去想几周后的问题，
like the utility bill or gas money or a credit card payment. As you're checking the prices and remembering the prices and figuring out if you buy two carats will you have enough money for breakfast, you are forgetting things you're paying less attention to, your rent, your kids' homework, all the other things that make your life complete. The thing is, as a result of doing this, the underlying problem can become worse. If you don't pay your bills,
比如水电费、汽油费或信用卡还款。当你核对价格、记住价格、计算如果你买两个胡萝卜是否还有足够的钱吃早餐时，你正在忘记那些你关注较少的事情，你的房租、你孩子的家庭作业，以及所有其他让你的生活完整的事情。问题是，由于这样做了，根本问题可能会变得更糟。如果你不付账单，
you'll be even deeper in the whole next month. Scarcity, in other words, is a trap. The scarcity trap for us is all those ways in which scarcity today, begets behaviors, which leads to even further scarcity tomorrow. And we think it's something that poor people do, busy people do. Here's another example. We think the lonely do this. So people who are lonely will often engage in social interactions in a particular way, which actually makes it harder for them to make friends.
下个月你会陷入更深的泥潭。换句话说，稀缺是一个陷阱。对我们来说，稀缺陷阱就是今天的稀缺会导致种种行为，从而在明天导致更进一步的稀缺。我们认为这是穷人会做的事，忙碌的人会做的事。这里还有另一个例子。我们认为孤独的人也会这样做。所以孤独的人经常会以某种特定的方式进行社交互动，这实际上使他们更难以交到朋友。
Just as the poor focus on the money they do not have, the lonely tend to focus on the friends they do not have. The result is they try too hard to be liked. In a conversation, the lonely person might be so preoccupied with making a good impression that he can't be attention to what's actually being said, the conversation falters. Instead of appearing likeable, he's seen as awkward or flatfooted. What happens is a result? People avoid the awkward conversationalist, and the lonely person becomes even lonelier. This lens offers a new way of thinking about why people who find themselves in scarcity
正如穷人专注于他们没有的钱一样，孤独的人往往专注于他们没有的朋友。结果就是他们太想讨人喜欢了。在谈话中，孤独的人可能太全神贯注于留下好印象，以至于无法关注别人实际在说什么，谈话变得磕磕绊绊。他没有显得讨人喜欢，反而显得笨拙或反应迟钝。结果会怎样？人们避开这个尴尬的健谈者，而孤独的人变得更加孤独。这种视角提供了一种思考新方式，解释了为什么那些陷入稀缺的人
seem to do things that, to an outsider, looks stupid. When you're in a hole, why would you dig yourself even deeper? Sandal says we're asking the wrong question. What if it's not the poor people are somehow deficient, but the poverty makes everyone less capable? That it's you and I tomorrow, where we become poor, would all of a sudden have the same effect? The poverty isn't some sense changing our minds. How do we know this isn't some bleeding hot theory to excuse irresponsible behavior?
似乎会做出在局外人看来很愚蠢的事情。当你身处泥潭时，你为什么还要把自己挖得更深？桑德尔说我们问错了问题。如果不是穷人有什么缺陷，而是贫困让每个人都能力下降呢？如果明天你我陷入贫困，是否也会突然产生同样的效果？贫困在某种意义上改变了我们的大脑。我们怎么知道这不是某种用来为不负责任行为开脱的空洞理论呢？
Elder and Sendville wanted to test their hypothesis. If all this is true, one thing that ought to be true is the same person when they're poor should have very different cognitive capacity than when they're rich. So how would we test that? Well, Well unfortunately we don't have the kind of money to go around making poor people rich, but sugar cane farmers actually create a natural experiment for us. Yes sugar cane farmers, specifically those in India who are
埃尔达和桑德尔想要检验他们的假设。如果这一切都是真的，那么有一点应该是真的：同一个人在贫困时的认知能力应该与富裕时有很大不同。那么我们该如何检验这一点呢？不幸的是，我们没有那么多钱去把穷人变成富人，但甘蔗农实际上为我们创造了一个自然实验。是的，甘蔗农，特别是印度的那些甘蔗农，他们
paid only once a year, right after the harvest. same person a month before harvest, poor and a month after harvest, well off. Again, you have the same group of people who are poor one moment and rich the next. Send the L'Henelda tested the farmers on their long term thinking when they had no money and when they had plenty of money. The results were stunning. We found a huge difference. So we found that post-hararvis when they're well off, they have much more impulse control.
一年只拿一次工资，就在收成之后。同一个人在收获前一个月很穷，而在收获后一个月很富裕。同样，你拥有同一群人，他们这一刻很穷，下一刻就很富裕。桑德尔和埃尔达测试了这些农民在没钱和有钱时的长期思考能力。结果令人惊叹。我们发现了一个巨大的差异。我们发现，在收获后他们富裕的时候，他们的冲动控制力要强得多。
Farmers who were rich tended to think about things that would help them over the long term. This matched other research that shows, for example, that farmers who are well off tend to weed their fields more regularly than farmers who are poor. Farmers who are poor mostly focused on how to make it to next week, short term thinking. To be clear, it's not that poor people focus on immediate needs because that's all they
富裕的农民往往会考虑那些能对他们的长期生活有帮助的事情。这与其他研究相吻合，例如，研究表明，生活富裕的农民比贫穷的农民更有规律地给田地除草。贫穷的农民主要关注如何撑到下周，这是短期思维。需要明确的是，并不是穷人只关注眼前需求，因为那是他们
want to think about. It's all they can think about. Scarsity captures the mind like it did with those starving men in Minnesota. In fact, scarcity can actually lower how you perform on an IQ test. Put simply, being poor is like having just pulled an all-nighter. Now, if you've been very lucky, maybe you've never experienced what it's like to be poor, or hungry, or lonely. But, there might be another form of scarcity you have experienced. On some days we get to leave at 4 p.m. some days we don't leave till 1 a.m.
唯一想要思考的事情。那是他们唯一能够思考的事情。稀缺抓住了大脑，就像明尼苏达那些饥饿的人一样。事实上，稀缺实际上会降低你在智商测试中的表现。简而言之，贫穷就像刚刚通宵未眠一样。现在，如果你非常幸运，也许你从未经历过贫穷、饥饿或孤独的滋味。但是，你可能经历过另一种形式的稀缺。有时我们下午4点下班，有时我们直到凌晨1点才离开。
So, and then you usually start the next day at 5.30 or 6 in the morning. Usually work 80 hours is a week. When we come back, we'll find out how being overworked and exhausted can produce its own form of scarcity. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain from NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Eldar Shaffer and Sendal Muleinathan believe that when something you desperately need is in short supply, your brain tends to focus on that thing.
所以，然后你通常在第二天早上5:30或6点开始工作。通常一周工作80小时。当我们回来时，我们会发现过度劳累和筋疲力尽是如何产生其特有的稀缺的。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆，您收听的是来自NPR的“隐藏的大脑”。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。埃尔达·沙菲尔和桑德尔·穆莱纳坦认为，当你急需的某样东西供应短缺时，你的大脑往往会专注于该物品。
This focus can be so intense that it impedes your ability to think about anything else. What happens when the thing you're missing is time. When you're so busy, it feels like you don't have time to breathe. Let me tell you the story of a young woman named Katie. She asked us to use her middle name for reasons that will be clear in a moment. For as long as she can remember, Katie has been driven, really driven. When I was in high school, I was determined to be valedictorian, so I took a sophomore level honors biology course as a freshman in high school, and I studied around the clock.
这种专注可能会如此强烈，以至于阻碍你思考其他事情的能力。当缺失的东西是时间时会发生什么。当你如此忙碌，以至于感觉连喘气的时间都没有。让我给你讲一个叫凯蒂的年轻女子的故事。她要求我们使用她的中间名，原因过一会儿就会明了。记忆中，凯蒂一直是个很有动力的人，非常有动力。上高中时，我决心成为毕业典礼的告别演讲代表，所以我在高一读了高二水平的荣誉生物课，我夜以继日地学习。
I had no cards. I walked through the hallways with the note cards. If there was a holiday party, I brought the note cards. And I'd also studied till two or three in the morning. Katie says she wanted to be perfect at school. She eventually got to medical school, where she excelled. She graduated at the top of her class and quickly started her residency.
我有抽认卡。我拿着便条卡走在走廊里。如果有节日派对，我也会带上便条卡。我甚至学习到凌晨两三点。凯蒂说她想在学校里做到完美。她最终进入了医学院，并在那里表现出色。她以优异的成绩毕业，并迅速开始住院医师实习。
The new schedule was grueling. You can get in at 5.30 or 6 in the morning and you round on all your patients and then you round with the team that means you go to all the patients and check in on their plan and adjust medications, et cetera, as necessary. And then there's usually a lunch conference
新的日程安排极其折磨人。你可能早上5:30或6点到医院，查房看所有的病人，然后和医疗团队一起查房，这意味着你要去看所有的病人，核对他们的治疗计划，并根据需要调整药物等。然后通常还有一个午餐会，
where we have education and then in the afternoon we might take new patients in and keep following up on our patients. And on some days we get to leave at 4 p.m. Some days we don't leave till 1 a.m. so and then you usually start the next day at 5.30 or 6 in the morning again and you get one day off a week. Usually work 80 hours is a week. As Katie's workload grew she started to feel she couldn't afford to waste a single moment.
我们会有教育培训，然后在下午我们可能会接收新病人并继续跟进我们的病人。有时我们下午4点就能离开。有时我们直到凌晨1点才离开，所以你通常第二天早上又要5:30或6点开始，一周只能休息一天。通常一周工作80小时。随着凯蒂的工作量增加，她开始觉得她浪费不起一分一秒。
Instead of spending any time relaxing, she started to focus only on things directly related to her success at work. When I first started, it was just really busy, so I tried to come home and I felt like, you know, I just don't have a lot of hours, so I need to make the most of them. And I was like, okay, I need to make sure I'm exercising, keeping my body healthy, and I need to read and stay on top of things. So I'd come home after a pretty long day, and I might go walking for half an hour, and then I'd read, and then I go to sleep. But then as the time went on, I decided to try to get in more exercise, because then I
她不再花任何时间放松，而是开始只关注那些与她在工作中取得成功直接相关的事情。刚开始的时候，事情真的很多，所以我试着回家，我觉得，你知道，我没有很多时间，所以我需要充分利用它们。我想，好吧，我需要确保我在锻炼，保持身体健康，我需要阅读并掌握最新动态。所以经过相当漫长的一天后我回到家，我可能会散步半小时，然后阅读，然后睡觉。但随着时间的推移，我决定尝试进行更多锻炼，因为我
never know when I'll get enough exercise in. So I started spending all my free daylight hours walking or running outside or going to the gym up to three hours a day plus like working 15 hour days and then trying to read and then go to sleep. As she focused intensely on the things she believed were key to her professional success, Katie lost sight of things on the periphery. She didn't know it, but she was entering the tunnel of scarcity. In her case, it was scarcity brought on by a lack of time. So I wasn't going to the grocery store. My house wasn't unpacked yet and it was stressing me out. And it was just a mess. And my clothes piled up. I had a lot of dirty clothes and coming home just felt so
永远不知道什么时候能得到足够的锻炼。所以我开始把我所有的空闲日光都用来在户外散步、跑步，或者去健身房，一天长达三个小时，再加上工作15小时的日子，然后试着阅读，然后睡觉。当她全神贯注于她认为对自己职业成功至关重要的事物时，凯蒂忽视了周遭边缘的事物。她自己并不知道，但她已经踏入了稀缺的隧道。在她的案例中，这是由缺乏时间引起的稀缺。所以我没有去杂货店。我的房子还没收拾好，这让我压力很大。那一团糟。我的衣服堆成山了。我有许多脏衣服，回到家感觉太
overwhelming I didn't want to be there and that's part of I think why I was walking so much just to get out of the house and get away from all the things I hadn't done and I also forgot to pay a bill in the mix of all of this. What did you forget to do? What bill did you forget to be? Um, it was my energy bill. The old Katie would have spotted all of this. I mean, you would just basically, at this point, almost falling apart, it sounds like. I was, I was falling apart.
让人不知所措，我不想呆在那里，我想这也是我一直在走路的一部分原因，只是为了离开家，远离所有我没有做过的事情，在这一切混乱中我还忘记付了一笔账单。你忘记做什么了？你忘记付哪笔账单了？嗯，是我的电费账单。以前的凯蒂会注意到这一切。我的意思是，在这一点上，你基本上快要崩溃了，听起来是这样。我当时确实快崩溃了。
There was something else. Katie had battled anorexia as a teenager. She knew she had to stay vigilant about her eating. But as she started to focus ever more intensely on work, she slipped back into some old habits. I was eating mostly vegetables and fruits, and I wasn't eating a whole lot else, maybe a cliff bar here and there.
还有一件事。凯蒂在十几岁时曾与厌食症斗争过。她知道自己必须对饮食保持警惕。但随着她开始更专心于工作，她又滑回了一些旧习惯。我主要吃蔬菜和水果，没有吃太多其他的东西，顶多偶尔吃一根克里夫能量棒。
No one knows better than a doctor about the importance of nutrition. And yet, despite all her medical training, Katie stopped taking care of herself. Here's one thing I haven't told you yet about scarcity. It can rob you of insight, insight about how your own mind is changing. Katie had no awareness that she was heading down a dangerous path. It became obvious to her only when it finally affected her work. I started to notice that I was like nearly missing things as I was reviewing for example. I admitted a diabetic and I almost didn't order insulin for them, but I did order the insulin.
没有人比医生更清楚营养的重要性。然而，尽管她受过所有的医学训练，凯蒂却停止了照顾自己。关于稀缺，我还有一件事没告诉你。它会剥夺你的洞察力，剥夺关于你自己的大脑如何改变的洞察力。凯蒂根本没有意识到自己正在走上一条危险的道路。直到它最终影响到她的工作，她才幡然醒悟。我开始注意到，例如在复查时，我差点漏掉一些事情。我收治了一个糖尿病患者，我差点没为他开胰岛素，但我最后还是开了胰岛素。
But I was like, I don't think I can keep up with this anymore because if you don't give a diabetic insulin, especially if they're type one, they can have very fatal circumstances in the hospital and get really high blood sugars that can cause them to have an acidosis and end up on a ventilator. So I turned myself in at the point that I saw that it was starting to affect my work. In two months of the residency program, Katie's body and mind had withered. Things had gotten so bad she had to go to a residential treatment center. Katie struggled with two things. Her body was desperately in need of nutrition.
但我当时想，我觉得我再也无法承受这一切了，因为如果你不给糖尿病患者胰岛素，特别是当他们是一型糖尿病时，他们在医院里可能会发生非常致命的情况，血糖变得非常高，导致他们酸中毒并最终插上呼吸机。所以当我看到它开始影响我的工作时，我主动承认了错误。在住院医师项目的两个月里，凯蒂的身体和精神都枯萎了。情况变得如此糟糕，以至于她不得不去一家住院治疗中心。凯蒂面临着两个挣扎。她的身体极度需要营养。
And her mind, she had to find a way to stop the intrusive thoughts that were consuming her. She had to... Learn how to just sit, because we weren't allowed to exercise, we weren't allowed to stand, we weren't even allowed to do jumping jacks or squats, we had to just sit. Katie's mind was filled with angry and impatient thoughts. At first I felt like I felt useless because I thought, you know, if I'm not doing something productive, what is my purpose in life. But gradually, as the program literally forced her to do nothing, Katie started to emerge from the tunnel.
至于精神上，她必须找到一种方法来阻止吞噬她的侵入性想法。她必须……学习如何只是坐着，因为我们不准运动，不准站立，甚至不准做开合跳或深蹲，我们必须只是坐着。凯蒂的脑子里充满了愤怒和不耐烦的想法。起初我感到自己毫无用处，因为我想，你知道，如果我没有做一些有成效的事情，我生命的意义是什么。但渐渐地，当这个项目字面意义上迫使她什么也不做时，凯蒂开始走出隧道。
She realized she had been so narrowly, relentlessly focused on one goal, doing well at work, that she'd ignored the very things she needed to succeed, moments of relaxation, like watching TV, or in her case, painting. Katie had loved art as a child, but she had put it aside because she thought it wouldn't help her become a better doctor. I'm kind of the type of person that just likes to study and then do after I've mastered it from a studies point of view. And so to just do something without instruction
她意识到自己曾如此狭隘、执着地专注于一个目标——在工作中表现出色，以至于忽视了她成功所必需的东西：放松的时刻，比如看电视，或者对她来说，画画。凯蒂小时候非常喜欢艺术，但她把它放在一边，因为她认为这帮不上她成为一个更好的医生。我属于那种喜欢先学习，然后等从学习的角度掌握了之后再去做的人。所以什么都不学就直接去尝试
is it feels very vulnerable to me, but it ended up kind of being my saving grace in my recovery and I've actually created an art room in my house. I changed my office from a work room into an art room and it has paints and watercolors and chalks and everything you can imagine and I try to go in there once a week and just create something without any expectation just for the purpose of creating it because I can. Kitty eventually returned to her residency program with a new outlook. She started doing something that Eldar and Sendele recommend to all busy people. She actually pencils time into our schedule to do nothing.
让我感到非常脆弱，但它最终成了我康复过程中的救赎，我实际上在家里建了一个艺术室。我把办公室从一个工作室改造成了一个艺术室，里面有颜料、水彩、粉笔和你能想象到的一切，我尽量每周去一次，没有任何期望地创作点东西，仅仅为了创作而创作，因为我能。凯蒂最终以崭新的面貌回到了她的住院医师项目。她开始做一些埃尔达和桑德尔推荐给所有忙碌之人的事。她实际上把“什么都不做”的时间写进了日程表。
One of the big things I've done is I kind of have a date night with myself once or twice a week, where I just schedule off the night and I won't do anything with anyone else and I'll just be free for me to do what I feel like it might be watching a movie, it might be taking a soak in the tub and reading a book, or being in my art room and painting whatever comes to me. But I do, like, I prioritize that and I actually won't accept plans with friends generally when I do this. So that's one of the things I do. Katie is consciously freeing up bandwidth.
我做的最大的一件事就是，我每周有一两次会和自己进行所谓的“约会”，我把那个晚上空出来，不和任何人做任何事，只留出时间让我做自己想做的事，可能是看部电影，可能是泡个澡读本书，或者在我的艺术室里随心所欲地画画。但我确实把这作为优先事项，而且当我这样做的时候，我通常不接受朋友的邀约。所以这是我做的其中一件事。凯蒂正在有意识地释放带宽。
And something strange has happened as she's done so. The less consumed she feels about work, the better she does at work. Honestly, it's kind of incredible, but at work, my brain has increased its capacity for fold. I am able to hold so many more things in my consciousness at once and manage them. I've just seen a really huge improvement in my ability to enjoy being in the company of others, to enjoy like occasions and to enjoy my work and do well at my work. While the psychological studies into scarcity and bandwidth are relatively new, the ideas are actually ancient. Avoid tunnel vision, keep difficult things in one
当她这么做时，奇怪的事情发生了。她对工作的焦虑感越少，她在工作中的表现就越好。老实说，这有点不可思议，但在工作中，我的大脑容量增加了好几倍。我能够同时在意识中容纳更多的事情并对它们进行管理。我真的看到我的能力的巨大提升，去享受与其他人的陪伴，享受各种场合，享受我的工作并把工作做好。虽然关于稀缺和带宽的心理学研究相对较新，但这些理念其实由来已久。避免隧道视野，把生活中某个部分困难的事情
part of your life from contaminating everything else. Be present. See you have a big deadline tomorrow for something you've got to finish. You go home and you're spending the evening with your kids. And in that moment, you're not present focused at all. What you're focused on is that deadline. You may go through minutes where you didn't hear what your kids were saying to you, because your mind keeps going to the southern side. Tunnel vision is not in itself a good thing or a bad thing.
与其它所有事情隔离开来。活在当下。你看你明天有一个必须完成的截止日期。你回家后和孩子们度过了一个晚上。那一刻，你根本没有专注于当下。你专注于那个截止日期。你可能会经历几分钟，根本没听见孩子们在对你说什么，因为你的大脑一直在想别的事。隧道视野本身并不是一件好事或坏事。
Shouting out distractions can be helpful at times. The question is, do you know when you're inside the tunnel? To me that's exactly the heart of managing scarcity. It's recognizing when are you trying to do something related to your scarcity or you really want to use that instinct? And when have you made a conscious decision to do something else? Where what you really need to do is to not have it in fruit on that something else. You're at home, you're with your kids, you chose to be a parent for that three-hour period.
屏蔽干扰有时会很有帮助。问题是，你知道自己什么时候身处隧道之中吗？对我来说，这正是管理稀缺的核心所在。它是识别你什么时候在尝试做与你的稀缺相关的事情，或者你是否真的想使用这种本能。以及你什么时候做出了有意识的决定去做别的事情？你真正需要做的是不要让它侵入到别的事情中。你在家里，你和孩子们在一起，你在这三个小时里选择了做一个父母。
You really don't want scarcity to improve them. Of course, it's easy to say, build free time into your schedule. Stay present with your family, take a vacation. These strategies presume you have choices. You can't say I've had it with being lonely, I'm going to take a vacation from being lonely. It's not a choice. And to me loneliness and poverty are the forms of scarcity that feel the biggest because
你真的不希望稀缺去侵扰他们。当然，说起来容易，在日程里安排出自由时间。与家人保持当下，去度假。这些策略的前提是你有所选择。你不能说我受够了孤独，我要去度个孤独假。这不是一种选择。对我来说，孤独和贫困是感觉最强烈的两种稀缺形式，因为
while all these forces are at play, there's no release valve, there's no escape mechanism. Elder and Sendoel want policy makers to design solutions that recognize how scarcity creates traps from which many people may not be able to extricate themselves, and they want the rest of us to stop preaching to those in poverty. If you look at programs at poverty, we often confound a little bit the attempts to help the poor, with the attempts to educate them. Make sure they show up in time, that they do the right things. From the perspective, we're taking with scarcity in some sense, if I'm very busy juggling
当所有这些力量在起作用时，没有释放阀，没有逃生机制。埃尔达和桑德尔希望政策制定者设计出的解决方案能够认识到稀缺是如何制造陷阱的，许多人可能无法从中自拔，他们希望我们其余的人停止向贫困人口说教。如果你看看扶贫项目，我们经常把帮助穷人的努力与教育他们的努力混为一谈。确保他们按时出席，做正确的事情。从我们对稀缺采取的角度来看，某种程度上，如果我正忙于应付
a very complicated life, insisting that I show up at the office at 8 and not 805, is not doing me a favor, I don't need to be educated. It's just hard to manage. You know, the transportation is not reliable. My kid is not ready. I don't have a babysitter. I'm going to make mistakes that it's not clear educating me in quotes about them is going to help me at all. It just makes my life all the more complicated. When people in poverty fail or make mistakes, the researchers think we should respond to them the same way we respond to mistakes made by airline pilots. There was a time not long ago when we thought that airline pilots who made mistakes were just bad pilots.
非常复杂的生活，却坚决要求我必须在8点而不是8点05分到办公室，这并不是在帮我的忙，我不需要被教育。这只是很难应付。你知道，交通不可靠。我的孩子还没准备好。我没有保姆。我会犯错，而引用那些东西来教育我是否真的能帮到我，这一点并不明确。它只会让我的生活更加复杂。当贫困人口失败或犯错时，研究人员认为我们应该以对待航空飞行员犯错相同的方式来回应他们。不久前曾有一段时间，我们认为犯错的飞行员只是糟糕的飞行员。
Sendle says a big reason air travel has become safer in recent decades is that there has been a shift in thinking about such mistakes. Designers have made cockpits fault tolerant. Rather than trying to find perfect pilots, cockpits are now designed to account for human error. The goal is to alert pilots when they've made a mistake and to diminish the consequences of mistakes. It's ironic that when we design cockpits, the entire mantra of fault tolerance seems so intuitive, but when we design social policies, nobody's out there talking about, let's make this fault tolerant. I mean, you know, poor people have a lot on their mind, they're bandwidth attacks, they're going to make mistakes. Let's make sure this program is robust when they do make that mistake. It's just not the way we think.
桑德尔说，近几十年来航空旅行变得更安全的一个重要原因，是人们对这种错误的看法发生了转变。设计人员使驾驶舱具备了容错能力。与其试图找到完美的飞行员，现在的驾驶舱设计是为了应对人为失误。其目标是在飞行员犯错时发出警报，并减少错误带来的后果。具有讽刺意味的是，当我们设计驾驶舱时，整个容错的信条看起来如此直观，但当我们设计社会政策时，却没有人出来谈论，让我们把这变得具有容错能力。我的意思是，你知道，穷人脑子里装了很多东西，他们的带宽受到了攻击，他们会犯错。让我们确保这个程序在他们犯错时依然能够稳健运行。这只是我们思考问题的方式不对。
If I offer a training program, I don't sit there and say, let me make sure, you know, what's going to happen? This is for low income individuals. Surely they're going to miss a few days because, know it's hard to get to class sometimes or other things around their mind. So let me design this curriculum so that it's in attendance tolerant. So even if somebody misses three days in a row they'll be able to come on that fourth day and still feel caught up. In fact, a training curriculum is often quite the opposite. If you miss three days in a row, it's an invitation to miss the fourth day because you're not going to get anything.
如果我提供一个培训项目，我不会坐在那里想，让我确保一下，你知道，会发生什么？这是给低收入人群准备的。他们肯定会缺席几天，因为你知道，有时候去上课很难，或者心里还有别的事。所以让我设计这个课程时，能容忍缺勤。这样即使某人连续缺席三天，他们也能在第四天来上课时，依然觉得自己跟上了进度。事实上，培训课程往往恰恰相反。如果你连续缺席三天，这就是在邀请你缺席第四天，因为你什么也学不到了。
Brandy Drew eventually turned her life around. She found a low-income assistance program that offered her help. She walked with a financial counselor who gave her strategies for budgeting her money and keeping track of long-term priorities. I actually have a calendar now that I write down everything to make sure I'm paying things on the correct day and time. It's taken time and little steps but Brandy is no longer in the scarcity tunnel. She's been working for a few years now and she has savings. I know that if anything happens, God forbid if I lose this job, I know that I can survive for at least six months if I have to look for another.
布兰迪·德鲁最终扭转了她的人生。她找到一个为她提供帮助的低收入援助项目。她与一位财务顾问合作，顾问为她提供了预算管理资金和追踪长期优先事项的策略。我现在确实有一个日历，上面记下了所有事情，以确保我在正确的时间和日期支付各项费用。这花了一些时间，迈出了小小的步伐，但布兰迪不再处于稀缺隧道中了。她现在已经工作几年了，并且有了存款。我知道如果发生什么事，哪怕天哪，如果我失去了这份工作，我知道如果我必须去找另一份工作，我至少可以维持六个月的生存。
Eldar and Sendal themselves say that they are constantly trying to keep the lessons of scarcity, front and center in their own lives. As a busy academic, Eldar has come up with a rule. When an invitation to an event two months down the road comes along, he asks himself whether he would attend the event if it were tomorrow. If the answer is no, he declines the invitation because his life is not going to be any less hectic two months from now. Preserving bandwidth, Dix conscious effort, most of us, Eldar included, are going to violate the Eldar rule. We'll say yes to new commitments when we don't have the time
埃尔达和森达尔自己也说，他们不断地试图将稀缺的教训放在他们自己生活的中心和显眼位置。作为一个忙碌的学者，埃尔达想出了一个规则。当两个月后的某个活动邀请到来时，他会问自己，如果是明天，他是否会参加这个活动。如果答案是否定的，他就会拒绝邀请，因为从现在起两个月后，他的生活也不会变得不那么忙碌。保持精力（带宽），迪克斯有意识地努力，我们大多数人，包括埃尔达在内，都会违反埃尔达规则。当我们没有时间时，我们会对新的承诺说“好”
or pull out a credit card when we can't afford it. In those moments, it's important to look up. To notice, we are inside a tunnel. After the break, we're going to switch gears and move from scarcity to excess. It turns out that having too much can have its own set of problems. When you're really wealthy, it's not uncommon to have the experience that everyone is out to get a piece of you. So it breeds a kind of suspicion.
或者在我们负担不起的时候掏出信用卡。在那些时刻，抬头看是很重要的。去注意到，我们正身处隧道之中。休息之后，我们将转换频道，从“稀缺”转向“过剩”。事实证明，拥有太多东西本身也会带来一系列问题。当你真的很富有的时候，有一种情况并不少见，那就是每个人都想从你身上分一杯羹。所以这滋生了一种怀疑。
Why are you being nice to me? Are you just trying to get me to give you something? And that must be very unpleasant. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you ever wondered what it's like to be rich? Taking all of her for detox in the Hamptons,
你为什么对我这么好？你是不是只是想让我给你点什么？那一定很不愉快。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。这是美国国家公共广播电台（NPR）。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你有没有想过有钱是什么感觉？带她去汉普顿排毒，
standardized testing has really stressed him out. Really rich? Why are you wearing a tux? It's after sex, would I am I a farmer? Private jet to your island estate in the Caribbean? Rich? I mean it's one banana, Michael. What could it cost?
标准化测试真的让他压力很大。真的很有富豪样吗？你为什么穿着燕尾服？现在已经过了六点（sex双关），我是农夫吗？坐私人飞机去你在加勒比海的私人岛屿庄园？有钱？我的意思是，这只是一个香蕉，迈克尔。它能花多少钱？
$10? Most of us will never know what that's like. But if you've ever been at least a little curious about the lives of the Uber wealthy, this next segment is for you. Brook Harrington is a sociologist at the Copenhagen Business School in Denmark. Several years ago, she decided to explore the secret lives of billionaires. Her strategy become a wealth manager. Brook discovered that in order to manage money for the super rich, wealth managers learn a lot about the private lives of their clients
10美元？我们大多数人永远不会知道那是什么感觉。但是，如果你对超级富豪的生活至少有一点好奇，接下来的这个板块就是为你准备的。布鲁克·哈灵顿是丹麦哥本哈根商学院的一名社会学家。几年前，她决定探索亿万富翁的秘密生活。她的策略是：成为一名财富管理者。布鲁克发现，为了替超级富豪管理资金，财富管理者们对客户的私生活了解颇深
and the very different set of rules that govern their world. Brook Harrington, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me on the show. For wealth managers to do their job, Broke, I understand that they need to find out everything about a client's life, not just a client's financial life, but everything about their life. Give me some examples of the kind of conversations people have with wealth managers and the kind of issues they bring up about their personal circumstances that might affect how their wealth is managed.
以及主导他们世界的截然不同的规则。布鲁克·哈灵顿，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我上节目。布鲁克，为了让财富管理者做好他们的工作，据我了解，他们需要了解客户生活的方方面面，不仅仅是客户的财务生活，而是他们生活的全部。能给我讲讲人们与财富管理者进行的对话类型吗？他们提出了哪些关于个人情况的问题，可能会影响他们的财富管理方式？
Well, it usually starts with what's called know your client activity. So if you were to come to me with me acting as the wealth manager, I would first ask to see some proof of identity like your passport, and then we would talk about what goals you had for your wealth and that begins the series of increasingly delicate and increasingly intrusive questions. Then usually we get into whatever real reason is bringing you to me. Maybe you want to avoid your taxes. Maybe you really don't like your family.
嗯，这通常从所谓的“了解你的客户”活动开始。所以，如果你带着我作为财富管理器来找我，我首先会要求看一些身份证明，比如你的护照，然后我们会讨论你对你的财富有什么目标，这就开始了一系列越来越微妙和越来越侵入式的问题。然后通常我们会切入你来找我的真正原因。也许你想避税。也许你真的很讨厌你的家人。
That's surprisingly common among wealthy people. For example, if you have a relative or if you yourself are engaging in some activity that might get you extorted, it may not be illegal, but it might be socially shameful. That's a financial risk that your wealth manager needs to know about. If you have a son or daughter with a drug problem, that's a financial risk that your wealth manager needs to know about. There can also be issues like I think I'm headed for a divorce, but I don't want my spouse to get half my assets. How do I
这在富人当中出奇地普遍。例如，如果你有一个亲戚，或者你自己正在从事某种可能让你遭到勒索的活动，它可能不违法，但可能在社会上令人感到羞耻。这是你的财富管理者需要知道的财务风险。如果你有一个有毒瘾的儿子或女儿，这是你的财富管理者需要知道的财务风险。还可能会有一些问题，比如“我觉得我要离婚了，但我不想让我的配偶分走我一半的资产。我该如何
hide those assets? Preferably offshore, so that whatever is legally provable as mine is such a small amount that it's not worth fighting about. So it's already interesting because these professionals in some ways get to know their clients better than the client's own family or friends or even their own spouse. Yes, it's apparently something of a cliche in the offshore world that the average client is a man in his 50s with a secret family somewhere. Might be a gay lover, might be a common law wife, and some children, but they're usually all sorts of secrets
隐藏这些资产？”最好是在离岸，这样在法律上能证明属于我的资产少到不值得为之争吵。所以这已经很有趣了，因为这些专业人士在某些方面比客户自己的家人、朋友甚至配偶更了解他们的客户。是的，在离岸世界里，这显然是一个有点陈词滥调的现象：普通客户是一个50多岁的男性，在某个地方有一个秘密家庭。可能是个同性恋情人，可能是个事实上的妻子，还有一些孩子，但通常有各种各样的秘密
that these wealthy folks wish to keep hidden, and that they have the additional privilege of being able to hire people to take care of in secret. So I understand you conducted about 65 interviews in 18 countries for this book. Tell me a little bit about the people you met. To be a wealth manager, you have to understand finance and the law. But this kind of wrote also calls for a certain psychological makeup.
这些富豪希望将这些秘密隐藏起来，而且他们还拥有额外的特权，能够雇人秘密处理这些事情。所以我了解到，为了这本书，你在18个国家进行了大约65次采访。跟我多讲讲你遇到的人。要成为一名财富管理者，你必须懂金融和法律。但这种工作也需要某种心理特质。
What kind of person becomes a wealth manager? Well, several of the people I spoke to describe themselves in only somewhat joking terms as social workers for the rich. So you have to have empathy and a desire to help people, but also a very high tolerance for people who would otherwise seem to be so extremely privileged that you might be otherwise inclined to smack them around and say snap out of it. You're lucky. You write in your book about the extreme lengths
什么样的人会成为财富管理者？嗯，我交谈过的几个人用多少有些开玩笑的词汇来形容自己是“富人的社会工作者”。所以你必须有同理心和帮助别人的愿望，但也要对那些在其他情况下看起来极其特权、以至于你可能原本想狠狠扇他们一巴掌让他们“清醒点、你很幸运”的人保持极高的包容度。你在书中写到了
that some managers go to please their clients or to provide services to their clients. You write about a manager named Alan Orin Geneva, who said that one of her clients once called her from outside a restaurant in London. Tell me that story. So this is one of the first stories that I heard that really made my eyebrows raise. While I was training to be a wealth manager, Eleanor told this story over lunch of receiving a phone call from a client who was in another country saying I've just lost my bracelet outside of a restaurant helped me find it. And the client didn't identify the restaurant by name. So imagine having someone call you from another country.
一些管理者为了取悦客户或为客户提供服务，不惜采取极端手段。你写到过一位名叫阿兰·奥林·日内瓦的经理，她说她的客户有一次在伦敦的一家餐厅外面给她打电话。给我讲讲那个故事。所以这是我听到的第一个真正让我挑起眉毛的故事。在我接受财富管理者培训时，埃莉诺在午餐时讲了这个故事：她接到一个在另一个国家的客户打来的电话，说：“我刚刚在一家餐厅外面弄丢了手链，帮我找到它。”而且客户没有指明餐厅的名字。所以想象一下有人从另一个国家给你打电话。
I mean, obviously the country was identified, but not anything remotely approaching a location. So you have to sort of marvel at the immaturity of the client expecting someone else to help her fix a problem like this. But Eleanor somehow did it. She determined where the client was and what exactly had been lost and got the local authorities on the case, found the bracelet and build the client for all the time. And apparently the client was happy to pay.
我的意思是，很明显国家是确定了的，但根本谈不上具体位置。所以你不得不对客户的不成熟感到惊叹，她竟然期望别人帮她解决这样的问题。但埃莉诺不知怎么做到了。她确定了客户在哪里以及具体丢了什么，并让当地有关部门介入调查，找到了手链，并把所有的时间都计费给了客户。显然，客户很乐意买单。
There are sometimes clients do make requests like this, not because they are acting childish, but because they actually have an ulterior motive. They actually want to test the loyalty's or ability off the wealth manager. You tell the story of a wealth manager in Hong Kong named David. Yes, he got a call early on in his relationship with a client in which the client said that he was in Japan and he was meeting with a Japanese gentleman who had expressed a desire for smoked salmon, and that this client had promised him, I think, a thousand sides of smoked salmon straight from the factory
有时候客户会提出这样的要求，不是因为他们表现得幼稚，而是因为他们实际上有不可告人的动机。他们实际上是想测试财富管理者的忠诚度或能力。你讲了一个在香港的财富管理者大卫的故事。是的，他在与一位客户关系的早期阶段接到过一个电话，客户在电话里说他在日本，他正在会见一位日本绅士，这位绅士表达了对熏三文鱼的渴望，这位客户曾向他承诺过，我想是一千条直接来自苏格兰工厂的熏三文鱼，
in Scotland, and was now calling David saying, get me the salmon. And David said, well, I'm your wealth manager, not your fishmonger. And the client said, well, today you're the fishmonger. And so David happens to know someone who knew the head of the Smokesammon factory in Scotland and he fulfilled the client's wish. And the client later told him, I basically made up that story. I wasn't sitting across from a Japanese fellow who wanted a thousand sides of Smokesammon. I just needed to see that you had the connections and the will to do what I wanted when I wanted
现在正打电话给大卫说，帮我弄到三文鱼。大卫说，嗯，我是你的财富管理者，不是你的鱼贩子。客户说，好吧，今天你就是鱼贩子。于是大卫碰巧认识一个人，那个人认识苏格兰熏三文鱼工厂的负责人，他就实现了客户的愿望。客户后来告诉他：“我基本上是编造了这个故事。我当时并没有坐在一个想要一千条熏三文鱼的日本同胞对面。我只是需要看看你是否有连接和意愿，在我想要的时候做我想做的事，并且不问任何问题。”
and not ask any questions. One thing that I got from your book is that there are important ways in which the very rich are very much like the rest of us and ways in which they are not. So wealthy people, unsurprisingly, turn out to have troubled marriages and wayward children, just like, you know, everybody else. But wealth, you argue, can compound those challenges. Well, apparently it's not uncommon for the wealth manager to be asked to find or recommend rehab facilities for kids. Or a parent will ask a wealth manager to break some bad news to the next generation to his or
我从你的书中得到的一点是，在很多重要的方面，超级富豪与我们其他人非常相似，但在某些方面又截然不同。因此，毫不奇怪，富人也会经历动荡的婚姻和任性的孩子，就像你知道的其他所有人一样。但你认为，财富会加剧这些挑战。嗯，显然，财富管理者被要求为孩子寻找或推荐康复中心并不罕见。或者父母会要求财富管理者把一些坏消息透露给下一代，也就是他或
her own children. Sometimes the wealth manager has to broker a truce between feuding family members. Say one family member feels that they've been done done by unfairly in the inheritance plan and has to be somehow brought back in so that they don't sue the family. The big risk here is if you have a disgruntled family member who sews, the lawsuit process in many countries makes public many, many private documents that would reveal the extent and nature of a family's wealth, all of which have been carefully guarded secrets. My guest today is a sociologist Brooke Harrington. She spent years trying to understand the lives of people who are so wealthy that they're able to circumvent the constraints of national
她自己的孩子。有时财富管理者必须在争吵的家庭成员之间斡旋停战。比方说，某个家庭成员觉得他们在继承计划中受到了不公正的待遇，必须以某种方式把他们拉回来，这样他们才不会起诉这个家族。这里的巨大风险是，如果你有一个心怀不满的家庭成员并提起诉讼，许多国家的诉讼程序会公开大量本来会暴露家族财富规模和性质的私人文件，而所有这些文件以前都是严加看管的秘密。我今天的嘉宾是社会学家布鲁克·哈灵顿。她花了好几年时间试图去了解那些极其富有的人的生活，以至于他们能够规避国家法律和边界的约束。
laws and borders. In the course of her many interviews with wealth managers, Brooke talked to one professional in Switzerland who told her a revealing story. So this wealth manager and her boss had been summons to a country outside of Europe by a client who was sending a private plane for them. She showed up at the Zurich airport with her boss waiting for this plane and she discovered that she'd left her passport back home in a different purse and she said to her boss, I've got to go home and get my passport because we're leaving Europe. And he said, don't worry about it. And she discovered that she'd left her passport back home in a different purse. And she said to her boss, I've got to go home and get my passport because we're leaving Europe. And he said, don't worry about it.
在与财富管理者的多次采访过程中，布鲁克与瑞士的一位专业人士交谈，对方给她讲了一个意味深长的故事。所以，这位财富管理者和她的老板被一位派私人飞机来接他们的客户传唤到欧洲以外的一个国家。她和老板在苏黎世机场等候这架飞机，却发现自己把护照忘在家里的另一个钱包里了，她对老板说：“我得回家拿护照，因为我们要离开欧洲了。”他说：“不用担心。”而她发现自己把护照忘在家里的另一个钱包里了。她对老板说：“我得回家拿护照，因为我们要离开欧洲了。”他说：“不用担心。”
And she said again, no, they're going to check my passport. They won't let me leave Switzerland, much less enter another country. I've got to go home. And he said, no, really, don't worry about it. So she didn't say anything for their figuring, you know, it would be his problem if she got refused the right to leave. Sure enough, the private plane pulls up, they get on it, nobody checks the passport. It lands in this other country outside Europe, nobody checks the passport, they get into
她又说：“不，他们会检查我的护照。他们不会让我离开瑞士，更不用说进入另一个国家了。我得回家。”他说：“不，真的，不用担心。”所以她什么也没说，心想，你知道的，如果她被拒绝离开，那是他的老板的问题。果不其然，私人飞机停下来了，他们上去了，没有人检查护照；飞机降落在欧洲以外的这个国家，没有人检查护照，他们上了客户派来的私人汽车，被带到客户的家里，他们开了会，私人汽车把他们送回私人飞机，私人飞机把他们飞回瑞士，他们下了飞机回家。
the private car sent by the client, they're taken to the client's home, they have their meeting, private car takes them back to the private plane, private plane flies them back to Switzerland, they get off the plane and go home. At no point has anyone encountered passport control or a customs agent. And this wealth manager's comment was, the lives of the richest people in the world are so different from those of the rest of us. It's almost literally unimaginable. National borders are nothing to them. They might as well not exist. The laws are nothing to them. They might as well not exist. It's potentially very very dangerous and I think she's
在任何时候都没有人遇到过护照检查或海关官员。这位财富管理者的评论是：“世界上最富有的人的生活与我们其他人的生活是如此不同。这简直可以说是不可想象的。国家边界对他们来说算不了什么。它们根本不存在也没两样。法律对他们来说算不了什么。它们根本不存在也没两样。这可能非常非常危险。”我想她是说得对的。
right about that. You spoke with the wealth manager named Dieter. I think this was a German wealth manager who talked about how his job allowed him to shmooze with powerful people, but also in some ways discovered things about foreign countries before even the citizens of those countries would find out about those important things. Yeah, he was very proud of the fact that when he was working in Africa, he would have parties and the heads of state of the various countries he lived in would come to his house and he'd get them drunk and they'd be spilling state secrets by two in the morning. parties and the heads of state of the various countries he lived in would come to his house
你采访了一位名叫迪特的财富管理者。我想这是一位德国财富管理者，他谈到他的工作如何让他与权贵们交际，但也在某种程度上比那些国家的公民更早发现有关外国的事情。是的，他非常自豪的是，当他在非洲工作时，他会举办派对，他所居住的各种国家的国家元首会来他的家里，他会把他们灌醉，他们在凌晨两点时就会吐露国家机密。他会举办派对，他所居住的各种国家的国家元首会来他的家里
and he'd get them drunk and they'd be spilling state secrets by two in the morning. And then people like Catherine Graham, the late publisher of the Washington Post, would call him up for advice. And you know, he could speak authoritatively about at least affairs in some African countries because he'd heard it directly from the mouths of the people who made those policies. It reminds me a little bit about what we learned when the Panama paper scandal broke. I kept seeing photos or drawings of the faces of people whose names turned up in the Panama papers and it was really a rogue's gallery of people from all walks of life, as well as heads of state and corporate leaders, people who you would
他会把他们灌醉，然后在凌晨两点时吐露国家机密。然后像《华盛顿邮报》已故出版商凯瑟琳·格雷厄姆这样的人会打电话向他征求意见。你知道的，他能够就某些非洲国家的事务发表权威看法，因为他是直接从那些制定政策的人口中听到的。这让我想起了一些我们在巴拿马文件丑闻爆发时学到的东西。我不断看到在巴拿马文件中名字出现的人的脸部照片或素描，这真是一群来自各行各业的乌合之众，以及国家元首和企业领袖，这些人你原本会认为彼此毫无共同点。
think have nothing in common with each other. But at one level, the fact that they are so rich gives them these very important things in common, which is to say, for them, national boundaries and laws are all optional. Taxes are optional. All forms of law are essentially, at that level of wealth. So this has come up recently in the US presidential election, when Donald Trump suggested that not paying federal taxes or avoiding federal taxes legally, I might add, for several years, made him actually someone who was smart.
但在某种程度上，他们如此富有这一事实让他们有了这些非常重要的共同点，也就是说，对他们来说，国家边界和法律都是可选的。税收是可选的。在那个财富水平上，所有形式的法律基本上都是可选的。这最近在美国总统大选中被提出来，当时唐纳德·特朗普暗示，不支付联邦税或在法律上避免支付联邦税（我顺便补充一下，持续好几年），实际上让他成为了一个聪明人。
He didn't pay any federal income tax. So, it makes me smart. As you tell me about these very rich people, drawn from different walks of life who have this thing in common, the fact they're very wealthy, talk a little bit about their attitude toward taxes and their attitude and obligations in some ways to footing the common bill. Some of them actually do sound a lot like Donald Trump. When I heard Donald Trump say that not paying taxes made him smart, and that if he had paid his taxes, they would have been wasted anyways. I was like, yep, he's the voice of a lot of very wealthy people around the world and
他没有缴纳任何联邦所得税。所以，这让我很聪明。当你向我讲述这些来自不同行当、却有着“非常富有”这一共同点的超级富豪时，请谈谈他们对税收的态度，以及他们在某种程度上对分摊共同账单的态度和义务。其中一些人听起来确实很像唐纳德·特朗普。当我听到唐纳德·特朗普说不交税让他变得很聪明，而且如果他交了税，那些钱无论如何也会被浪费掉时，我想：是的，他代表了世界各地许多超级富豪的心声，
their wealth managers who said essentially the same thing to me. They are very committed to neoliberal ideology and very committed to the idea that these elite clients are doing the world a favor as wealth creators. So I'm fascinated because what you're saying is that in effect the wealthy and their tax managers don't just think they're doing something that's practical and expedient. You're saying they actually feel like they're doing the moral thing? There is a very strong component of ideology here. You see this in the Wealth Management Training Program. You see it among at least about a quarter of the people I interviewed really seem to believe quite unironically in the justice of protecting the wealth of
还有他们的财富管理者，他们对我也说过本质上相同的话。他们非常坚定地信奉新自由主义意识形态，非常坚定地认为这些精英客户作为财富创造者是在为世界做善事。所以这让我着迷，因为你的意思是，实际上富人及其税务经理不仅认为他们在做一些务实和权宜之计的事情。你是说他们实际上觉得自己是在做合乎道德的事情吗？这里有非常强烈的意识形态成分。你在财富管理培训项目中可以看到这一点。你在我采访的人中至少四分之一的人身上看到这一点，他们似乎非常不加讽刺地相信保护客户财富免受税收侵害的正义性。
their clients from taxation. They literally view taxation as theft and they view government in general as being incompetent at best, corrupt at worst, and they're deeply suspicious of any sort of welfare state programs because they see it as destroying initiative. I think a lot of people have impressions of the lives of the very wealthy and imagine what life must be like when you're jetting around on a private plane and being waited on by service staff all the time. And I'm wondering in your conversations with wealth managers whether any of your own assumptions or beliefs about the connections between wealth and happiness were either confirmed or challenged.
他们简直把税收视为盗窃，把政府普遍视为往好了说无能、往坏了说腐败，他们对任何形式的福利国家项目都深表怀疑，因为他们认为这会摧毁积极性。我想很多人对超级富豪的生活都有所想象，并想象当你在私人飞机上飞来飞去、随时有服务人员伺候时，生活会是什么样子。我在想，在你与财富管理者的对话中，你对财富与幸福之间关系的任何假设或信念是否得到了证实或挑战。
I was struck by a man I spoke to in the Channel Islands who talked about how suspicious wealthy people are. It jibed with some things that I've seen personally. And what he said was, when you're really wealthy, it's not uncommon to have the experience that everyone is out to get a piece of you. It's like what happens to a lot of re-winners, all sorts of so-called relatives come out of the woodwork, asking for loans, asking for help of some sort. Con artists come out of the woodwork, looking to get a piece of you. But that's what happens throughout the lifetime of wealthy people. And so it breeds a kind of suspicion. Why do you want to be my friend? Why are you
我被我在海峡群岛交谈过的一个男人深深触动了，他谈到了富人是多么猜疑。这与我个人所看到的一些事情不谋而合。他说的是，当你真的很富有的时候，有一种经历并不少见，那就是每个人都想从你身上分得一杯羹。这就像许多中彩票的人遭遇的那样，各种所谓的亲戚从四面八方冒出来，请求贷款，请求某种帮助。骗子从四面八方冒出来，想要分你一杯羹。但这在富人的一生中都在发生。所以这滋生了一种怀疑。你为什么想成为我的朋友？你为什么
being nice to me? Are you just trying to get me to give you something? How that would lead at the extreme to a sort of Howard Husey and retreat or isolation from people, because if you can't trust anyone, why bother? I mean, the sad thing that you're saying is that the wealth manager might end up being perhaps among the very few people that a rich person can trust. Yeah, I think that seems to be a common story. It's wealthy people and their servants. It almost comes to the point where you can, if you're a wealthy person, you are more trusting of the people you pay to be in your service than the people you don't pay because with your family, you might have sort of
对我这么好？你是不是只是想让我给你点什么？这在极端情况下将如何导致一种霍华德·休斯式的隐居或与人们的隔绝，因为如果你不能信任任何人，又何必去费心呢？我的意思是，你所说的悲惨的事情是，财富管理者最终可能成为富人可以信任的极少数人之一。是的，我想这似乎是一个普遍的故事。富人和他们的仆人。这几乎到了这种地步：如果你是一个富人，比起那些你不用付钱的人，你更信任那些你付钱让他们为你服务的人，因为对于你的家人，你可能会遇到一种
a kinglier problem, which of my children actually loves me and which are out to get something from me. But at least when you are having a transactional relationship with an employee, at least the boundaries there are clear. You're paying them for certain services and you can assess whether they are giving you those services at the standard you require. If they're not, you fire them, if they're doing a good job, you keep them on. There's a simplicity to that that is not present in emotional relationships.
更棘手的问题：我的哪个孩子是真的爱我，哪个孩子是想从我这里捞到什么？但至少当你与员工进行交易关系时，那里的界限是明确的。你为某些服务付钱给他们，你可以评估他们是否在以你要求的标准为你提供这些服务。如果没有，你解雇他们，如果他们做得好，你留用他们。这里面有一种简单性，而这种简单性在情感关系中是不存在的。
Brooke Harrington is a sociologist at the Copenhagen Business School in Denmark. She is the author of the book Capital Without Borders, Wealth Managers and the 1%. Broke, I want to thank you for talking with me today. Thank you. This episode of Hidden Grain was produced by Jenny Schmidt, Renee Clark, Raina Cohen, Maggie Penman, Chloe Connolly, Chris Benderev, Parth Shah and Laura Quarelle. Our editor was Tara Boyle, our team includes Thomas Liu and Camilla Vargas. If you liked this episode please be sure to subscribe to our podcast and please tell one friend who might enjoy our show. Thanks for listening. I'm Shankar Vidantum. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
布鲁克·哈灵顿是丹麦哥本哈根商学院的社会学家。她是《无国界资本：财富管理者与1%的人》一书的作者。布鲁克，我想感谢你今天与我交谈。谢谢你。本期《隐藏的大脑》由珍妮·施密特、蕾妮·克拉克、雷娜·科恩、玛吉·彭曼、克洛伊·康纳利、克里斯·本德列夫、帕尔特·沙阿和劳拉·夸雷勒制作。我们的编辑是塔拉·博伊尔，我们的团队包括托马斯·刘和卡米拉·瓦尔加斯。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必订阅我们的 podcast，并请告诉一位可能会喜欢我们节目的朋友。感谢收听。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。下周见。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任何句子即可发表评论。